Nintendo.
I didn't expect it to be that loud.
I couldn't hear it.
You too will come to understand.
Fear as I have.
What's going on?
Surround sound!
Making pasta.
I've always been pasta.
um also um uh tis himself thank you for the 10 gifted um
i don't think we watched this before did we
witchcraft oh oh handless man who oh just kidding That's
yelling.
Is that a boob?
Oh, pun.
Oh, oh my god, space.
What is going on?
This is making me even more confused.
Oh, nasty.
Ew!
Oh, torture.
Math.
Outer wilds!
That's on the cover.
I came back for my vacay at Niagara Falls back to Minto.
Jay, welcome back.
Eternal.
Oh.
Die.
Oh, never mind.
It's not eternal.
That's just for the second.
Huh?
That
confused me more than everything.
What?
I still don't know what this game is about.
Welcome back, everybody, to Eternal Darkness, Sanity's
Requiem.
My sanity has been revoked.
The math is the scariest part of the game.
That's what I'm saying!
It's loud, is it?
I can't tell which one you're hearing, sorry.
Is it okay now?
Wait, can you hear that?
Can you still hear the game?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
You can?
You can still hear the game!
Oh my gosh, no wonder it's so loud for you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I thought you were hearing it.
Through...
Well, then maybe...
If I do this, can you still hear it?
Oddball!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Sorry, we're doing a sound check now.
You can still hear it?
Oh, perfect!
Huh.
Interesting.
I'm learning things.
Ready to continue?
The adventures of Pius Augustus are our favorite lich.
Pius Augustus!
Okay.
Cool.
I learned, actually...
from that, actually.
Good morning.
Oh, good stream.
Have a good stream bit.
I thought it was a good morning.
May have a happy birthday.
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Zinara.
The game is heavily inspired by HP Lovecraft.
Not just his monsters, but the style of his writing.
I see.
I'm gonna be honest, you guys.
I am so tired today.
I don't know.
Maybe because I, um, I didn't sleep very well last night.
And yesterday I, uh, streamed for like, what, five hours?
And then I recorded that day and then I also recorded today.
So I'm so eee-pee!
I'm so eee-pee.
So I'm not sure how long I'll go.
We'll see once I start getting into it.
Maybe I'll stay out.
I can't even speak.
Paragon.
What is the Paragon?
Everybody keeps mentioning the Paragon.
I want to be in on the joke too.
really sorry about the sound.
I didn't realize, um, where you guys were hearing it from.
So, um, it's just some, it's some tech stuff on my end.
I thought, but now I've learned.
So you guys actually helped me out a whole bunch.
You don't even realize it.
Paragon, paragon.
What's the paragon?
It will become very apparent what the paragon is.
Paragon, paragon, paragon, paragon, paragon, paragon, Oh my
god.
Ronan, welcome to membership, thank you.
Yeah, so let's not waste too much time talking because...
Oh god, I'm already yawning.
I have a coffee now.
I have coffee.
We'll see how far I can get.
Look where Anthony in 814 AD.
Yippee!
Oh, the darkness columns.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's right where we left off!
This is actually perfect because I can...
Whoa.
Cinema.
Whoa, whoa.
The darkness comes.
Anthony.
Yeah!
I'm gonna turn it up just a bit.
How do I run?
Nope.
This is a stand.
Okay, this is how I select, like, which arm and stuff, I
believe, right?
I have to be like, head, right arm, left arm, get him in the
nuts, you know, and then I run.
Oh, this is how I run.
Okay, nice.
Left trigger to run, yeah.
And so we're here in good old ye old 1814.
We're trying to talk to this guy here.
We need to talk to Charlemagne because I think he's gonna
get...
I think he's gonna get...
Kilded.
This is one of my favorite games of all time.
You're one of my favorite tubas of all time.
I'm so happy you're playing this game.
Thank you, Rota!
Thank you!
Yeah, there was this dead guy over here.
Ooh.
What happened to him?
Anthony sees the body of a monk.
His rhyment, rhyment, turn off the game console.
Is that of his order.
Stained with blood that has seeped from many grievous
wounds.
It's truly a disturbing sight.
Vivikor, thanks for the gifted.
We just can't stop staring, though.
We have like this gruesome, morbid curiosity, right?
I'm a good...
I go to church.
Look.
I'm a good guy.
haha oh my gosh
but I can't leave either this game we have to go upstairs so
basically last time we open the way he runs is so funny the
way he runs is so funny but we opened up this whoa secret
passageway and I have to climb down and probably be
bombarded by bozos that was a good alliteration bombarded by
bozos.
You got that scroll.
Oh, yes.
How do I do this magic?
We also got the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
We got that.
Very nice.
I'm going to make myself a weeb.
Ted smaller.
There we go.
Hey, Min, thanks for the stream.
Really needed.
Oh, thank you.
Last minute work has now destroyed my sleep cycle.
I have a three mile run in three or four hours.
do you have to do the run
we got this urn not quite sure and then our wait no this is
the scroll that we're trying to give to Charlemagne for some
reason we just can't knock we don't know how to do that um
oh shoot wait is it under spell list we know nothing we're
kind of dumb yeah Anthony does not have enough components to
attempt to research spell he does not have enough such an
insult and when i start using that oh you just don't have
enough components to attempt to do this at the moment cat
peeing on the rug in the early hours of the morning it's
messed up my oh no not the cat pee i'm so sorry
not that you have eternal darkness save on your memory card
you should probably go back to the psychomantis boss and
twin snakes oh my gosh you're right
though we got this one rune it's it says it's called the
circle of power but clearly not powerful enough we can't
even do a quick spell oh okay that's okay so it'll be on the
d pad okay and then oh gosh i'm so not used to i never had a
um a game cube growing up so i love how you said tome of
eternal darkness.
Oh, oh, I love how happy you said tome of eternal darkness.
So why?
Okay, that's why.
Alright, now that I have saved, I have no fear of death,
maybe.
Oh!
Ah!
Already?
Oh, my God.
God.
No, sir.
Ah!
Let's get his arm!
Get his arm!
Take out his other arm!
Take out his arm!
Finish him!
I
found a magical rune!
Good job, Anthony.
How's the sound, by the way?
Oh, runes are the key element in creating spells.
By collecting and combining runes in different ways,
different spells can be created.
Okay.
I'm gonna make a new spell.
Dang it.
I have a Rune.
Question mark, question mark.
Sounds good?
Okay, cool.
Oh.
Anthony.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I forgot the music is so freaky in this.
Oh!
Okay.
Try it.
Do you have a rune for me?
Ouch!
It's okay.
I don't know.
Wait, I don't have a way to heal.
Not like the last person.
Are you gonna come up too?
Yep, okay, good, good, good.
Come here.
Come here!
Ha!
I'm getting pretty good at this fighting thing.
Good news, I got an interview tomorrow!
Oh my gosh, so disgust!
Good luck, good luck!
Oh.
Oh my god, Anthony does not look well.
Oh my god!
Oh,
it revealed a door.
Oh, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, don't worry!
Hey, hey!
Hey!
Wait, come to me!
Don't get him!
Oh my god, no, no, no!
Hey!
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
Chill, go after this guy.
Here.
Go after his other arm.
There.
Go after his arm.
Go up.
There we go.
No, no, finish him!
Did I save him?
Or...
I got a torch!
Can I only have one of these equipped or...
Oh my gosh, it's one or the other.
Wait, but they died by this.
What's that?
Broken green urn.
Oh, there's urns here too.
This function allows the player to combine two or more items
from the inventory into one.
Two thirds.
There's more you.
I never cared for idle things, but recently I watched a 10
minute video on how the mix came to be.
Didn't get me with MGS yet, though.
I'll get you.
I swear.
you i'll get you my pretty i've i don't know if that's okay
assembled is like assembled i think is a um is a bit of a
stretch you know it's okay anthony don't worry about it can
i place it here oh wait maybe here
oh i can't i can just check it fragments of a broken urn
pieced together to form a crude hole.
Deep cracks mar its structure and while it is almost
complete, it is far from watertight.
Perhaps it can be repaired somehow.
Do you think the monk was supposed to do that?
I didn't mean it.
I didn't kill him though.
He fell.
He took one hit and fell.
I tried to save him.
He should have... Oh my god.
I wish I could...
Look at Anthony's staring at it.
Oh, is it coming this way?
I hear you.
Ah!
Oh no!
I pushed him down the stairs.
Uh, finish him?
There's no way to finish him.
Magormore!
He was going to give you a long sword.
Oh!
Oh shoot.
A carved stone tablet lies on the stone floor.
Maybe the guy should have just left.
Oh, let's pick it up.
Magical...
The codex.
Ruins cannot be understood without a codex.
Without a codex, runes in your possession will remain a
mystery.
Okay, what runes do I got now?
I'm smarter.
I have the codex.
Oh, Magomore.
Oh, I understand now.
I'm so confused.
That guy came all the way up the stairs just to see me.
Oh no, what's wrong, Anthony?
Oh, he would look really bad.
Oh my god.
Look at these sassy guys.
They're fighting.
The girls are fighting.
Okay.
gonna go i'm gonna sneak up on this guy oh can i finish him
if i hold on because i'm gonna need more what's it called
right i'm gonna need more sanity at some point so if i
finish him switch it out right finish him easy yeah so i
just switch it with the equip the torch and then we nice
i'll Uh, a red urn sits beside the fountain.
Lucky!
A filled red urn.
And we can fill up...
Oh, there's another...
What are you looking at, Anthony?
You're scaring me.
You're making me nervous.
A slab of etched stone sits on the pedestal.
Sinity is overrated.
Drink the water.
Lucky!
A disturbing rendition of a monstrous devil!
Okay, buddy, calm down.
It's a statue.
It is contorted into what appears to be a fountain, or it
was built that way.
It was carved that way.
What sickly liquid is this draining into the pool, trickling
from a scum-encrusted spout?
It's water, Anthony!
Chill out!
Anthony has never heard of water before.
for him.
Wait, can I use the... Let's see.
Hey!
You clumsy!
While fumbling around, the urn slips from Anthony's stiff
fingers, dashing itself into fragments as it hits the floor.
Anthony picks up the broken floor.
Wait, we got a rune in there.
Wait, maybe I was supposed to do that.
This one.
Oh, oh, yeah, weath.
We still don't have that one.
Wait, can I make a new spell?
I think I have enough.
Okay, everybody, I have enough components.
Wait.
I have the components.
Oh!
What did I make?
Oh.
I don't think I'm doing it correctly.
Uh...
Ah!
Spell one!
What's it do?
The effects of this spell are unknown.
Not all of its components are in your possession or have
been identified.
Spell one, baby!
We'll put spell one.
Oh, uh, spell, we're gonna assign spell one to here.
Yeah!
Good job, Anthony.
One.
Spell one.
Back away from that, it's dangerous.
Cast it?
Oh, what if it's like a, okay.
Oh, oh?
Wait, but I...
Oh, select an item to enchant?
Scrasmus axe?
Oh,
this magic, this meter...
Magic meter represents a character's magical energy.
When a spell is cast, the level will get lower.
This meter regenerates whenever the character is in motion.
May the rats eat your eyes.
The darkness comes.
It will damn us all!
The rats!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Let's go test- Okay, Anthony, you look really bad.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Eek!
This guy's really big.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Hey!
Chill out!
Okay.
God!
It's still enchanting.
what it's doing.
I think it's working.
Wait
for me!
I'm coming to...
What if you check it now?
Oh, good idea.
This Frank and Saxon weapon relies on a hefty blade to
deliver deadly cutting and slashing attacks.
It does not have a handguard as it was designed for
offensive rather than defensive fighting.
Nope, okay.
Don't blame Anthony.
He's only ever had ale and beers.
since his mother weaned him.
Oh, it opened for us.
Ah, I see, I see.
So when we step on the platform, an ancient stone tablet
leans against the bookshelf.
Ew.
Yo, wait, what's that down there?
Oh, that's the blinking of my sword.
He's only had ale and beer.
I've been entertained by your bonds for years now.
I'm finally tuning in live for Eternal Darkness.
for entertaining me all these years.
Seek!
Thank you!
Amongst the books on the table, rests an ancient scroll of
what appears to be paper.
Enchant item.
Oh, way ahead of you, game.
Cinderathalos, thanks for the 10 gifted!
I am way ahead of you.
I am so way ahead of you.
This allows the player to cast spells that have been found
or researched selecting this allows players to assign their
most used spells to a button this will enable the casting of
spells without having to choose them from the book each time
through this function the player can examine the contents of
each spell scroll that has been acquired oh that which is
broken shall be fixed that which is dull will be sharp thus
is the nature of the enchant item magic oh it's sharp for
now This spell requires Antorbok And these sound like
Pokemon for real.
Antorbok.
Mag or more.
Okay.
I've already done it.
Thank you.
Oh no, it's taking me through the tutorial.
No, please let me out!
Let me out!
I can't...
I...
Okay, I'm gonna have to assign it there as well.
Okay, now I can leave.
Anthony, are you okay?
you're looking mighty green buddy you're looking so bad oh
my gosh thank you guys for all the super chats thank you so
much finally got a job after being un slash underemployed
for 11 and a half months holy cow cuddly your streams are so
helpful in keeping me motivated tough time so happy i can
afford to super my ocean out no save it you deserve it you
earned it i want to i want your spells.
Oh!
Was that OBS?
I don't know what just went.
Am I still streaming?
Also ties into three colored bars your character has.
Wait, what?
Pokemon rules.
I'm here?
I don't know what just happened.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, what did this say?
Religious text on unspeakable nature written in languages
utterable only by My monsters are corrupt humans.
Ooh.
Okay.
Open that up.
And now run for it, Anthony.
Run for it!
Oh.
The bishop passed through the secret door.
There has to be a way to get through it.
Anthony, you look so dead.
Do I need some... It looks like...
Hmm.
What else can you enchant?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
The things that we needed to be fixed!
Then also this one!
Wait, how's my magic looking?
Oh, it doesn't drain that much.
Um...
Okay.
Ha ha!
Although the urn appears to sit correctly in place on the
pressure plate, it does not appear to be heavy enough.
We gotta go get the water.
We gotta go...
Okay, Anthony.
Anthony, you look so...
Buddy, I'm really concerned for you.
I'm really concerned...
He doesn't look good at all.
He looks like he's about to kill over.
There's nothing in here, right?
Yeah, okay.
Use.
Dunking the urn into the foul-smelling fountain, it becomes
filled to the brim with rank fluid.
It is a lot heavier now, and rife with...
Fotor.
Fetter?
Fow...
Alright, let's get going.
And Trigo is like so much money gifted.
Thank you so much.
Let's all be reckless.
with our money.
Now!
Oh my gosh, Anthony.
I love your laugh.
Dang.
Use...
Wait, wait, what do you mean?
It's not heavy enough.
Wait, all three of them will be heavy.
All three of them will be heavy enough.
It means stinky.
It like...
Just panning over to the already open door and like making
the sound as if it like, you know.
Oh, it's kind of spooky in there.
As if, you know, it wasn't already open.
Am I going to have to...
Wait!
I just noticed.
I'm going to make it sharp.
I heard we're being reckless with our money.
I don't think so.
Oh, wait, he's alive.
Oh, no, he's not.
I've come to return my book.
Very well, then.
For your efforts.
He looks kind of like me.
I lost a quick and merciful death.
No!
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
He's the guy!
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Oh, gosh.
Get him!
Get his ass!
Oh my god, run away!
Run away!
Oh my god, run!
Cut off his arm, please!
Oh, I got one of his arms!
Nice!
I got his arm!
Yeah!
I thought he was gonna be a good guy.
You're not a good guy at all!
Finish him!
Uh-oh.
He didn't get again.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, there we go.
Anyway.
Oh, run away.
Oh, get his arm.
Get his arm.
Get his ass.
Oh.
The juke's.
Ah,
go away, Anthony.
Go away, Anthony.
Anthony, my buddy.
The Charlemagne's gonna see us and be like, this is...
That doesn't seem like a good place.
What if we do put the book there, though?
Oh.
A shrine to a god that bespeaks of an ancient evil that
graced the earth before mankind walked its valleys.
I'm going to put the book there.
Oh, never mind.
I can't.
Touch the pedestal.
I'm trying.
Won't let me.
Do I go this way?
I guess now that we have the bishop key, we go back to
Charlemagne?
Is that the door that it opens?
Oh!
Oh god, Anthony!
Anthony!
Oh my god, Anthony, no!
He looks like...
Oh, Charlemagne's gonna kill us.
Holy!
Spooked me like crazy!
Yeah, take that!
Charlemagne's gonna kill me.
Um, he kind of reminds me of like, I don't know, for some
reason, like, the Sims or something.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I should have known.
Let's just get out of here, Anthony.
We don't need to fight.
Don't be greedy.
Who's coming at me?
What the hell is that?
Um...
Maybe it's a friend?
Yeah.
What?
I was just looking at Mokopis earlier and they look like a
Mokopi.
The trap for dimension sprawls in every direction whilst in
this place magic cannot be cast and humans are subjected to
odd phenomena.
The portal cycle from color to color as time progresses and
only the quick will escape.
Um.
Uh.
What?
Do I need to go to the blue light over there?
Oh, oh shoot, not the red one.
Blue?
I'm in the shadow realm, for real.
Okay, let's go to the blue!
Oh shoot, there's a guy there.
It's okay, I can get his ass.
Oh, all I know how to do is hit rocks, man.
Get his arm!
Come on, his arm!
Yeah.
Wah!
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
My Dono's thing...
Hold on.
My Dono's thing is all messed up.
Wait, I can't see it.
Refresh?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
There it is.
Everything is acting weird today.
I'm the ultimate wizard.
Slaps you limply with his arms.
Ah, that urn looks as good as new.
So true.
Okay, there we go.
I think this is how I get out.
This looks healthy.
Oh!
Never mind.
I lied.
Uh, what's purple?
That looks like an exit.
For sure.
That has to be an exit.
Get out of here, Anthony!
You're turning into a zombie.
Yay!
Okay, so avoid the scorpions, I guess.
Trappers have no eyes but can sense sound very well.
If Anthony can sneak past them, they won't be troubled.
How quiet.
Sneaking mission real.
Hit the door.
Oh my gosh, don't come this way.
I'm moving one pixel at a time.
Oh.
Yay!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Get the other guy!
Oh my god, there's three of them.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Kill him out!
Just strike him dead!
I wish I could get his head.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah, get his...
Take him out.
Enchant war off?
We'll take him.
We'll do it.
We'll fix it.
La la la.
I don't think...
Surely, Charlemagne will be fine.
And there will be nothing that is attacking him.
I believe.
Oh yeah, let's do our...
Our magic.
Our chant, our sword.
Oh, I forgot!
I should be using my torch instead.
The torch is kind of awesome.
Anybody here?
Not even a poor sad dead bishop.
Oh god Anthony.
Oh no!
Oh no no no!
Oh god Anthony!
Even his hair is graying.
Oh gosh buddy.
Oh he doesn't like this the light.
Oh he doesn't like the light.
Oh interesting.
Okay, I'll re-equip my sword then.
Oh, cool!
He might be me.
Casually returns to the world of the living looking like
this.
Ooh, buddy, I think you're...
Oh!
What the h- Thank
you!
Oh!
No!
You can go back down the ladder.
Thank you.
Yes, save and continue.
Okay, we're good.
It's the same picture.
I think it's still fine though, right?
It did save though, right?
Three hours and...
What do you mean cheater?
It's again?
You guys say cheater to anything.
Okay.
The time did change.
Okay, great.
Um, holy shoot.
Ah, my god!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, oh my god.
My game is in reverse.
Wait, or something?
What's happening?
No!
Oh, run!
Ouch!
Oh gosh, what's happening?
Uh, do I do I do?
Um, magic?
Where's this torch?
Equip this instead, maybe?
Do you like this?
Take that!
I'm gonna die, I'm about to die.
I'm about to die.
I caught up a piece of him.
I'm examining the...
How am I still alive?
Oh gosh.
I don't know what's happening.
How am I still alive?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
The controls here are very weird.
Oh, I killed him!
I don't know how...
I don't know how I won!
Let's go!
Zero sanity.
Not anymore!
Whew!
And...
Anthony, are you okay?
Oh shit.
Ah!
Wait!
No!
Please!
Anthony, are you okay?
Wait.
Was that part of the sanity?
Was that...
Part of the...
I even... I turned my control on and off.
That was a sanity effect?
No way.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
Don't kill me, please.
Please, don't kill me.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I should have saved after...
Ouch, out, out, out, out.
Please.
Ouch!
Run away!
Anthony!
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to survive.
Hold on.
You know what?
It'll be fine.
I am going to save.
But we'll save in this slot.
Just save and continue.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
The torch, you're right.
You're right.
The torch would be better here, I think.
Yeah, and then we'll just switch it over.
What the?
He's dying!
Tiny, tiny, scaly man!
Oh my god.
But it's not letting me finish them.
I think they're too small.
Oh, the game!
Ah!
Isn't really happening!
Oh, it's not?
Wait.
What's happened?
Yeah!
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Anthony, don't die.
Okay.
What's going on?
happening oh my god so when something is actually happening
it i um i'm fine i can continue forward but something's not
actually happening when my sanity is being crazy crazy oh my
god even the the the tilt um okay all right the bishop's key
we have it we have it Oh.
You are
a fool for trying to save him, Anthony.
His fate was decided many centuries ago, as is the fate of
this world.
Despite your faith, there is little to save you from the
power of Shelly.
Oh my god.
Was that Roy Campbell?
Oh my gosh.
Colonel jump scare was so funny.
Anthony turned the game console off right now.
Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
Okay, we're back as she.
Oh gosh.
Wait, can I do spells now?
Anthropococococonium.
Why can't?
So what I learn...
Anthony was liquid.
Oh yes, I do remember that.
I swear to God, I heard...
There's...
there is little so save you from the power of shadow moses
we're all we're all so brain-rodded oh gosh oh neat so now
okay cool my sanity is getting a little freaky second floor
key let's go
what's that here here Oh, oh, oh, I thought so.
I'm scared.
Okay, the game is actually starting to scare me.
Hold on, I keep adjusting the audio a little bit because I
think it's getting kind of loud.
What you learn in the book, you learn in real life.
I'm reading!
Oh, gosh.
Thank you.
The entire VA cast for this is just an MGS reunion.
I'm afraid of...
A jelly man coming out of somewhere.
I'm afraid of having to fight.
My sanity is not that low.
Hamburger.
Bang, bang, bang.
Ma'am, we're here to talk about your car's warranty.
Wait, is it the front door?
Hello?
Okay.
Weird things are going on in this place.
I mean, weird things have been going on.
Oh, is it this door?
Uh-oh.
Wait, maybe we shouldn't.
The, like, AOL sound of the door closing.
Oh, what's this on the ground?
Oh, that's not what I thought I was examining.
I thought this is a forest.
Okay.
This is a horse?
How can my Yoshi be this spooky?
Whoa, what was that?
Did you guys see that?
There was, like, blood or something.
Serene painting of a luscious melting valley delicately
rendered in oils time has taken its toll on the surface
which is which is soiled with dirt and scratches us skellies
are afraid of ghosts as well so we're even wait you didn't
see it okay oh wait no you guys it's right there and also
this guy was looking at me funny hello we're just not gonna
we're not Huh?
We're just...
Okay.
We're just not even gonna talk about that one.
That's fine.
I'm looking up at something.
What am I looking up at?
What are you looking up at?
Everything's bleeding.
Grandpa?
You seem a little paranoid.
Just maybe... I don't know.
Detail.
Alex questions the presence of a lush landscape amidst these
other morbid pieces.
Could it be a single ray of hope encircling by encroaching
darkness?
An eternal darkness.
Oh!
Some runes.
One of the drawers in the dresser curiously has no keyhole.
And its place is a small triangular design flanked by a
magical symbol.
What does it mean?
So I need to get that.
Oh, the bathroom.
There's an opening.
Oh, Journal of Maximilian Roivus!
When are you going to start playing the game?
You've been staring all this time.
Are you muted?
That would be so freaky.
Do I have this one?
Let's check my spells.
My runes.
I don't have these runes.
Oh my gosh.
Legendary scare.
Okay.
Wait.
Was this here?
Was this swan here before?
This guy just staring at me.
Okay.
maybe so what about you grandpa really good screams today oh
I think it's because I'm tired this place is so big Napoleon
oh a chapter page has been hastily stashed behind the frame
of this painting should Alex retreat yes the gift of forever
oh yeah we also have to read the um the journal entry let's
see check this is a page from maximilian rovis's journal it
reads everything that brightened my life now engulfs me in
darkness i fed on the light of truth yet starved on the
shadows of lies i have learned through my lifetime but no
less than a newborn baby That's exactly how I feel right
now.
The gift of forever.
I want to keep exploring a little bit more before we go into
the next chapter.
A musty aroma hangs in the air.
And a layer of fine dust.
Mike Tyson's ass.
Oh, sorry.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thanks for the fine gift of it.
Yesterday we're good too.
She literally screamed for ice cream.
Hmm.
A layer of fine dust lies on all the surface of the room.
It seems as if no one has been in here for a long time.
It's almost like a museum.
It belongs in a museum.
We got some revolver ammunition.
Uh-oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
My sanity is not so low for it to be turning the screen like
that.
My sanity is not so low for you to twist the camera around.
Okay.
Six shots.
Why is it allow you to look at every shot?
Oh!
Okay.
Grandpa?
Can I also just walk through?
The wallpaper in this section of the hallway is oddly
marred, as though the wall it sits on is not even with the
rest of the room.
Oh, uh...
Never mind.
Great grandpa.
Snail.
It's too dark in here to do anything.
Perhaps the circuit has been broken.
Okay.
Glad it left for us.
Just push it.
I know.
Just do something.
You can do it.
Just...
Do something with...
Just do something.
What?
Somebody's hungry.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there's a rune there.
I didn't even notice that I couldn't touch it.
The stained glass depicts a glowing medieval maiden.
The faint light of the setting sun.
Setting sun.
The maiden clasps a piece of parchment in her hands.
The widow gives Alex a strange feeling, almost as if it is
magical.
Not really there.
A glowing field of energy protects the window.
Okay.
Oh, if you get real close to it.
The setting sun.
Okay.
I like her idle animation.
That's fun.
Okay.
There was one other thing I wanted to check before we...
Um...
Before we do the next chapter.
And that's this door.
Does this look different?
No, I think he looks the same.
Never mind.
Okay.
I think I'm getting really paranoid.
Is the door...
Was it in here?
Yes.
This is, I think, the same rune that's on the dresser.
Stop it!
Alright, let's go to the gift of forever!
Who are we now?
Dreams.
Modern psychology offers only unproven theories.
as the meaningless tossing and turning of a brain settling
into a restful sleep.
Others see them as laden with symbols of our unconscious
desires.
To still others, dreams represent the upwelling of the
archetypes, normally hidden deep within the recesses of the
human collected unconscious.
Of one thing I am certain.
After a brush with the ancients, our dreams metamorphosize
into nightmares.
Wait.
65 AD.
We went back in time?
We're in Persia.
Oh no, get this guy some water.
He's going to start hallucinating.
I have implored you for years.
Yet you ignore all my advances.
You dominate my dreams.
Wow.
And I can think of nothing else.
I fear I desire you many hundred times more than you love
me.
my life has become a waking dream Kareem I for weeks oh I
have dreamed of an ancient treasure so precious that it
changes all life around it it must no wonder he's desiring
her if you truly desire me as you say then you will find
this for me bring this treasure to me and I will be yours
both of our dreams dreams will come true.
She's just like Kagoya.
I need nothing more than you.
Oh my god.
You have enthralled me to the point where I can think of
nothing else.
This boy.
Promise.
This guy is suffering from a symposis.
You will not forget about me.
I think she will.
You need not worry.
I desire nothing more than the treasure that you seek.
Leave now, Karim.
And I shall await you.
Simp, simp, simp.
Um, he's like, this has gotta be it.
Oh no, there's guys all around here!
Uh-oh, they're gonna start attacking me.
Uh, good job!
You made it!
Oh, what do I have?
What is this?
Talisman.
An ancient talisman that has been in Kareem's family for
many generations.
It is said to bestow long life on those who have kept it.
This item can be used to restore health.
And chakrams.
The chakram was a favorite throwing weapon through Central
Asia in medieval times.
Kareem isn't voiced by anyone from Metal Gear, but the girl
he's sipping for is voiced by laughing octopus.
No way!
A balanced ring of metal sometimes beautifully decorated.
It would be hurled at an attacker.
Heavy chakrams could sever limbs or heads.
However, they were not designed to return to the thrower.
Oh, well, that's kind of...
But what I can do...
Oh, I need the Tome of Eternal Darkness first.
Can I get that axe?
Let me get that axe, though.
A man's corpse lies fallen.
Wounds cover the exposed flesh of his body where his armor
has failed.
Why is the music so loud?
It's just dead.
The big guy and then the tiny little guy right next to him
is so funny.
Sounds spooky down there.
Oh, let's get our tone.
Yay, I'm walking on you!
Oh my gosh.
This is what I should do for you guys.
If you're just like, gosh, I wish Mint would step on me.
Actually, any VTuber.
I feel like I wish VTuber would step on me.
Just line up.
There you go.
Build in what appears to be a leathery hand.
Excuse me.
A mysterious book.
It is bound and healed.
human skin and intricately decorated, excuse me, with
shrunken bones and beckons and yours to be possessed.
Yes!
Take the towel!
Uh-oh.
They woke up.
Whoa, that's a lot of guys.
Um.
Let's enchant my sword.
Oh!
That didn't work!
Because I went outside the runes!
Interesting, okay.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, run!
Run!
Yeah, let them fight.
Let them take care of- Oh.
Uh...
Finish them!
I think I got him!
There we go.
Uh...
Because he's made of bones!
Is this like a Skelly...
Oh man, I missed out.
Can I leave or...
What do you want me to do now, game?
Do I go back down?
Oh, okay.
What is that?
Are these guys gonna come alive?
Yes, come over.
I didn't realize...
Oh, shh.
I didn't realize that, like, getting their head was so
powerful.
I always thought getting the arms was better.
He wasn't tiny, he was average-sized.
Yeah.
He was smaller than the rest, though.
Statuette vaguely resembling a man.
Stands atop a low pedestal.
It looks like Gru from... from despicable me.
Heard his little feelings.
Well, I didn't mean to.
Okay, I guess that guy is fine.
Oh!
Come here.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, he's got a rune.
He's got a rune.
Oh, yes.
Let's save.
Thank you
Oh, he's confused Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Am I good?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, violence is happening.
Yeah, yeah, he kills them so haphazardly.
Let's see if I can save if they'll let me.
No!
What let me say?
It's too dangerous here.
Still?
Still too dangerous?
Is anybody else alive?
Darkness.
I did Kareem so dirty with this picture!
Why is he the cross-eyed?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's going on here?
I can't tell what's happening.
Oh, the lanterns are...
There's like a fire.
Okay, cool.
We have to do this before we continue.
What happens when you simp too much, you go cross-eyed?
He's crazy in love, you guys.
He's crazy in love.
Oh!
Oh, the top one, okay.
I'm actually...
What is this puzzle?
I have no idea.
You know what?
Let's examine it first.
An arcane shrine dominates the room.
Braziers surround its edge.
While a larger one tops its summit.
No doubt each one would be filled with incense to facilitate
prayer to insidious deities.
Okay.
Braziers.
I'm kind of confused.
Oh, yes, we got the new rune.
You're so right.
Also, let's...
Oh, we have this guy, too.
See, it's particularly heavy for its size.
Maybe.
I wonder if it, like, allows us to duplicate him.
This new spell, new spell.
New spell, new spell, item, wait, project, item.
Wait, this is the same one that I did before, isn't it?
This one.
No.
Simping, simping all for nothing.
No, he's gonna get the girl, I believe.
Did I do it this way?
No.
I never get the girl.
He's gonna get the girl.
the girl.
Wait, but there was nowhere else for me to go, which is why
I'm kind of confused.
Or was there?
La la la!
Dead end.
This guy will re-animate at any moment.
There was nothing in the first room, right?
I don't think so.
No, then he...
How is he supposed to get back?
He's finding the treasure!
And then he is gonna go back to...
Was there a combination I didn't do?
Was there a combination?
I can't...
Oh wait.
Oh no.
Yeah, there's only these two rooms.
He did all the combinations.
Okay.
Are you okay?
Buster.
A symbol on the barrier?
I don't think I can grab it, though, right?
A chorus skating barrier blocks Kareem's progress down the
ladder.
This shimmering energy creates the vision of a rune upon its
surface.
Oh,
I can't take him back!
He's stuck there.
I think.
Oh, no!
Our statue...
Rune order does not matter, only correct magings.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's good to know as well.
Huh?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I just had to touch it.
No way.
It was so easy.
What about this then?
What was the point?
Okay.
Where's the Skelly?
That's me.
I'm covering.
Oh!
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, take his head.
Take his head.
Uh, you.
Yeah, take his head.
No, don't take this yet!
Finish him!
Yeah!
Yeah, Karim!
A statue vaguely resembling a man.
Pick it up.
Nice.
And I'll take that.
Yui!
Wait a second.
Climb down again, Karim.
Have a question.
You can take the torch!
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gaming now for real.
So now we can put...
Use?
This is exactly what learning kanji is like.
Oh, what is that?
Karim, what did you do?
Karim.
Kareem.
Kareem, not good.
Where do we go, Kareem?
Where do we go with this?
With these guys all around here.
Kareem.
Kareem!
We're gonna get attacked!
No, no, no.
Just a box.
Just a box, I got good.
Yeah, yeah.
Just a box.
I'm gonna go to the center.
I'm gonna go to this thing.
Yes!
Just go.
Just go, Kareem.
We did it!
Oh,
okay.
We can go back up if we feel like it.
I'm walking with a purpose here.
Go, cover it.
Oh, who's that?
Lucky.
No comment.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, oh, boy.
Uh-oh.
Lying in a pool of cold blood is a dead soldier.
He is a victim of an unseen battle.
Perhaps this man died from the claws of the monsters of this
place.
It is difficult to tell.
This guy's got his own little thing here.
The man lies dead.
Anointed in blood from the ravages of a Tollwar sword.
The wounds deep and numerously fresh blood, precise, yet
powerful.
The result of a man's actions, not a monster's.
Wait a second, what's my sword?
Oh, I have one too.
But mine's also a Tollwar war.
Can I have both of them?
Karib!
Can't dual wield!
I'm kitty to real oh my gosh look at me yo Kareem is awesome
so far
yeah also someone asked maybe I should change up the
brightness I'm going to make it a little bit brighter for
you guys just in case save and continue okay save
Let's see how it is now Because Oh my god no I did it I took
your sword Oh Oh
What's the point of use of dual wielding if you're not fast
Oh there it is there it is Oh my god what the hell is that
Oh my god push push push
Am I okay is my health okay Alright we're alright Paton on
the sanity system in fact expired i didn't realize it
expired right so awesome
oh what's happening oh my god grandpa my dear alex i will
always be at your side there are times when insanity takes
hold and nothing seems right during those times i will help
you grandpa am i insane for i will keep the darkness away
Grandpa, Grandpa, I'm reading.
This isn't really happening.
Is it?
Oh shoot.
Oh my insanity.
Come on, get the head, get the...
Oh!
Oh
my gosh!
Oh yeah!
What the hell is...
Oh my gosh, these things are so crazy!
Oh my god.
Okay, I just took out that guy.
And now, whatever this thing is...
Okay, is this dead?
Oh, my insanity is really bad.
What happened?
What happened to my insanity?
I think they're called bone stealers.
Do these guys, like, make me...
Do these guys drain me, it seems?
Another dead man.
Who were these men whose corpses litter the dungeon?
Unwary soldiers who stumbled inside were grave robbers
looking to plunder it.
A crumpled scroll lies under the dead man's curse.
old fingers.
Recover!
Green guys drain sanity.
What did I just get?
The map's looking a little sussy.
New spell.
Wait, spell list.
Check.
A tattered scroll from an ancient text.
It reads, the spell enables the transfer of magical power
from the environment to the self.
Restoration of the body, spirit and mind is in its purpose.
Norakath and Santok.
Norak.
Oh,
I don't have...
I don't have those.
No!
This game.
Oh my god, that's me.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, there's a lot of guys here.
Okay.
Sigma out one by one!
Finish him!
Kshah!
Turn the game console off.
Now, Raiden.
Oh.
Wait, so if I touch this.
Touch.
It worked before.
You picked green at the start of the game.
You fight more insanity draining monsters in this
playthrough.
Oh.
Wait, that's...
I actually prefer that because I like to see this...
The sanity effects, I'm not gonna lie.
But if my sanity gets too low, it says I start to drain
health too, right?
Wait, I can't even save in here!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even notice this!
Stinky!
Uh-oh.
Okay, wait.
Uh, no.
I need to go to purple.
Purple!
Oh, purple!
Oh, no, not red.
I...
Uh, purple!
My insanity!
Oh,
finish him?
Oh, no.
Stop.
Are you kidding me?
Run!
Get out of here!
Uh-oh.
I just tried to save the game.
Now it'll let me.
Okay.
Um, this isn't great, but uh, cool.
You're doing just fine.
It freezes me.
Ow!
Get him!
Oh
gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
this thing.
Use?
Oh, it was just happening.
Oh, it was a...
Wait!
No, I was supposed to heal!
Oh, gosh.
I'm so done.
I'm so dead.
Run, run, run.
Get out of here.
Open the door.
Oh, my gosh.
I thought actually that oh okay oh no i think i i think i'm
gonna have to do it from here okay he's still missing an arm
so oh oh i can get this i can make it get his arm get his
arm come on oh my gosh please it's so hard to aim oh gosh oh
gosh oh gosh please get the i'm trying to aim for the arm i
really am oh my gosh oh what's happening please just find a
Just find him!
Oh gosh, I'm gonna die again.
I'm gonna die.
This is it.
This is it for...
This is it for Kareem.
Just kidding.
Get out of here!
Oh, there we go.
Get behind him?
Okay.
I'm gonna use all my health in this one fight.
If I have to reload, I will.
But...
Now, um...
embarrassing.
Finish it, please.
I need the insanity!
Magical Codex.
Holy cow.
I'm gonna save, but like, in this slot.
Just in case.
Since we have very few health left.
New spell.
Wait.
What do I have?
What are my runes?
We need Narakoth and Santok.
This one, probably.
Woohoo!
Oh, my sword!
You're right!
We shouldn't...
We got the recover spell, though.
Oh.
Hello?
Uh...
list oh there we go assign recover there we go enchant item
recover yes we should totally um oh wait hold on we'll do
this we'll enchant our sword
yuppie and then we'll and recover
Oh shoot, I have no magical energy.
Yay!
Yeah, I gotta keep moving.
That's right!
Wait, open the door?
Oh, okay.
Why am I huge?
Am I huge?
Am I humongous or is it just me?
The sanity effects are so funny because some...
Oh, but look at that!
it still went away even though it like reset the room can i
recover now
oh let's do it again
wait i'm not recovering health oh that's a little silly
there's also a room in here It does literally nothing.
The metallic plaque replaces the lock.
A colored sigil is engraved on the metal above the wide
slot.
Slot appears to be wide enough to insert a large lid.
Don't I know that one, though?
Recovering mana with mana.
What is this?
I thought I was recovering health at least.
What did I...
Oh, I think I'm talking to myself again.
Stone tablet
The age ceiling has collapsed Creating an impassable pile of
rubble that blocks the doorway I don't think I have a lot of
ruins Walking with the purpose He's like, I'm here to get my
girl Oh The Dutch angle is like really
He's doing Otage
Cinematic Of course I guess I'll grab that And what Regret
it afterwards Sorry I'm safe scumming now But that's
a A large ram dao Broad sword protrudes from a solid
pedestal Of made of stone It awaits the next owner That's me
Karim Karim That's kind of an eyeball on it and everything.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
That's quite a few guys that we got here.
Uh, check it.
Um, a formidable weapon that enables the user to strike a...
Many enemies at once still keep a distance.
With a sweep, Karim can knock down enemies and can cause
extreme damage with an overhead attack.
Let's go?
Oh gosh, run Karim.
Like, don't know where to walk.
Finish him!
Nice.
Oh gosh, out, out.
Finish him!
So much sanity.
Yummy sanity!
Sanity, sanity!
Oh no, my sanity!
Wow, that was so easy.
Holy cow!
Guts mode?
Oh, uh, again!
Again!
They're draining my sanity like crazy though.
Like, even the sanity that I get back is drained, I'll
drain.
Oh, no!
All the sanity I get back is drained.
Again, again!
No, stop draining my sanity, please!
I need it!
The music just stops.
Let me spot you some sanity.
Thank you!
Is that it?
Oh my gosh, more!
Oh, this guy's got a rune!
Stop taking my sanity!
Oh, it's a big guy.
I forgot that I can...
Oh, yeah!
Wait, my health!
Oh, it's this thing.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
Oh, God, hit it!
Please!
Oh, gosh!
Karim!
Oh, I hate these skinwalker things.
They're so gross.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
No, please!
Karim!
I'm not gonna make it.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
I can barely run.
Oh, this thing is faster than me!
Please, please just die.
Oh god.
I can't hit it.
Oh, please.
It's too squiggly.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, it's dead, but so am I.
Aim.
No, it's literally.
I think it's literally because it's like...
How do I describe it?
It's like...
I think I can't get too close to it, you know?
I don't know.
I can't I aim for it, but it's just Oh my gosh, went away
One HP in a dream, baby
Kareem has perished at the hands of the eternal darkness
With no one to stop their diabolical plans Humanity will
surely be annihilated The end Of course the little Stupid
stickman comes out
Oh, it's so frustrating It's okay, we saved right before it
The darkness comes The darkness comes Oh, Kareem Chakrams
Oh, for those things?
Okay Yes
Here we go Okay
I want to enchant it, but I don't think I can.
I think they'll get me first.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, where am I?
Oh, God.
I can't see where I am, you guys.
Ah!
Close.
Not far enough, I guess.
Uh.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Take him out!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Kareem?
Kareem, we were doing so well before.
What happened?
Kareem, you're losing...
You're losing your edge, buddy.
Oh my god, geez.
You
only got the one guy.
Oh, are they infighting?
No.
Come on!
Take him out!
Go.
Finish him.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, Kareem.
We're okay, Kareem.
We got this.
Come on, Kareem.
We can...
Even if it's just one more...
We got this!
Take it!
Finish it!
Finish him!
Okay.
Heal now?
That's a good idea.
Oh, that gave us a lot.
Nice.
Ah!
He's right next to me!
He is right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god.
Whoa,
holy cow.
Yeah!
Now we're gaming, Kareem!
Oh, I'm trying to finish him, but...
I'm trying.
There we go.
Oh!
Hopefully that counted.
Finish him!
This guy over here, headless.
Unable to...
He's so unsure.
You okay, buddy?
They don't even count him as an enemy.
The music stopped.
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Get up!
You still got some fight in you!
Oh, enchant!
You're right.
Uh, oh, I did the wrong thing.
There we go.
Okay, enchant this.
I wonder if it still worked.
Yeah!
Wait, are these the guys?
No, not yet.
Uh...
Oh,
can I finish this guy here?
Finish him?
These angles are so bad for measuring distance.
It's really, it's, it is tough.
Oh, oh, you're still up!
You did it!
Overhead all these fools.
Yeah, baby!
Alright.
Maybe I should take him out first.
because the other guys um they transform and i don't want to
deal with them where'd he go hello are you still over here
are you still lying down where'd you go oh there he is he
was lying down no way can
i leave wouldn't that be hilarious
this new thing so i'm nervous about it rip and tear man rip
and tear oh shoot i'm nervous i'm nervous check the spells
uh new spell oh
self is it really
Recover...
Now does it...
Wait, but it's not in the thing.
Recover green flavor.
Yeah, but like, I have to do it afterwards, I think.
I don't... I... Unless I can do it over here.
No, I just recovered more mana.
Hey, why didn't it work though?
Okay, now...
Wrong alignment?
Oh.
It didn't assign it, but it's also not in here.
It's not under my...
assign?
Oh, I see!
I see, I see how it works.
I see, I see, I see.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, that makes more sense.
Maybe actually I should assign it to Y.
Paragon, paragon, paragon!
How are we paragoning?
Okay, this thing, right?
The chakrum?
I'm scared to use it.
Unless... Do you think the torch will work too?
Oh
my gosh, don't just stand there, I guess.
Ah!
No it does not.
Um, great.
Good to know.
Awesome.
Why did I, why did I allow both of them to come out at once?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh
Okay.
Please don't die.
Oh my god.
Please.
I can't tell where the thing is.
Oh, I got it.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, close.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, my health is...
Not great.
Hereupas sand to Zelda.
Ooh.
I live somehow.
Hereupas sand to Zelda.
But not very...
Okay.
Hereupas sand to Zelda.
Oh.
My heartbeat.
A wind's away.
Yeah, but like...
If I can't make it out...
If I have to go through it again...
I shouldn't have... I don't know why I let both of them come
out at once.
That was... That was me just not thinking.
But you know...
I'm slow.
I'm steady.
Save?
Yeah, you're right.
Well...
I'll save in this one because if I feel like I can't
continue because my sanity is way too long, then it will be
bad.
Or not sanity, you know, my health is what I'm in.
Where did I?
Oh, this way, right?
Yeah.
There was that door we need to open.
Okay, we were hobbling along.
I thought maybe if I cast it in front of the door, it would
work.
I
can use it.
Oh, there we go.
Korean places the blade in the slot, but feels it pushed
back.
It is as if the magic of the blade does not fit the law.
Oh.
Okay, we need to make it green.
Oh, whoops.
New spell, baby.
Um, item?
What was the other one?
There we go.
Item spell.
I love item spell.
Uh, cast item spell green upon the sword.
Yippee!
That's how we open it!
Oh!
Oh wait, I forgot to.
Fuse!
Green apple flavor!
Is this a door over here?
Kind of looks like it would be one.
Oh my gosh, my health.
Karim, you're worrying me, buddy.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh Ah, don't finish him Wait, come
on Cool, yeah, we are so sane Um I think we're I am like, I
am so aware of the world Right now I am so sane I am I am
Maybe I'm not as sane as I thought I've taken my meds.
I've taken my meds.
I know that there's a ladder right there.
I'm just seeing if there's anything.
I wish this game had like health.
Here we go.
I thought they weren't able to hear.
You can take my sanity.
It's fine.
It's fine if you take my sanity.
I don't need it.
I'm good.
Any chakrams left?
I'm so sane, I'm seeing the player through the screen.
What is that?
What's that action figure?
A ruby effigy stands upon the pedestal centered in the room.
It's mine now!
What did I do with this?
A small statuette of a defeated warrior.
That's me!
Kneeling in respect to an unseen victor.
It is made from a deep red ruby.
Okay.
Is it Anthony?
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Go ahead, take my sanity.
Just don't trap me, please.
Do I leave?
Is there anything else in here?
I guess I leave.
No, there's...
simp just like me?
Okay.
Trappers can sometimes be helpful.
If I go into the shadow realm, sometimes there's health.
You know how there was like a magic restored thing?
Is there sometimes a health restored?
I'm a little... I'm afraid Little Caesar's crazy bread is
currently just regular bread to you.
Oh, yes?
Oh.
Should I go then?
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's not that many guys here either.
So red?
Maybe?
I can't see what's over here.
Makes me a little nervous.
Go to red.
Wait, was that a guy?
Yes, it is.
Okay.
Hello!
Hello, sir!
Um...
Can you see me?
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, oh, oh!
I could think I caught him.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh, my gosh!
It worked!
Wait, what is purple?
Oh, purple is to leave.
Oh, my gosh!
Okay, so this is how the trappers work.
Interesting!
And now we're like basically...
We're basically Gucci.
We're so good.
Nice!
I'm so healthy!
Oh, are you still alive?
How?
How are you still standing?
He's like, I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh,
that was great.
Oh.
I'm so healthy, maid who's already dead.
Kareem is healthy.
These are kind of cute.
Here I go in slow motion.
Drop her.
I hardly know her.
I
hope you're not.
Okay.
Whew.
Walk.
Yippee!
Oh, Kareem!
I'm so happy for you!
Now...
Now what?
We have this little...
We have our figurine?
What do we do with him?
Oh, save?
That's such a great idea.
You guys are so right.
in fact i'm gonna go over the first one since we're so back
baby since we are so back baby
where do i go from here hold on i'm checking the map
control pot oh c c stick here we go we are so back baby i
think you can continue down the hallway this one oh this one
I don't think so I'll check again though doesn't hurt
oh along the length of the corridor the ceiling has given
way and collapsed littering the floor with debris oh climb
ah what's there oh it's this guy oh my god Oh my god, no!
You're just a normal enemy, no!
That's messed up!
Oh, shoot.
Come on, I'm trying to get your...
I'm trying to get your arm!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
My...
He's taking out my magic.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Whoa!
That's a big ol' boost.
Magic is fine, though.
We just can recover.
This is why we save.
Yeah, we'll just run around and we're good.
But my health is already halfway.
That's insane.
Blue weak to green.
Wait, so because I chose...
Because I chose green at the beginning, I'm basically like a
grass type.
and so that's why i can kill him quickly
or wait do i
you need the green enchant yeah if i enchant it because it
was blue when i enchanted it blue and then green this game
is so much more complex than i thought it was like in a good
you know like there's so much more to this game than i
see mostly wait what was my hold on because I see mostly
green guys I should keep my my weapon blue decided to play
this again since you started I ended up dying twice in a
later chapter where you have a shotgun because I was
impatient rushing with traps always be patient thank you for
the reminder oh wait red okay red beats green okay okay okay
okay I get it I get it I get it Oh, what a peculiar roof.
What the hell is that?
A blasphemous sculpture made from human skin and bone.
A trestle of bones is cradled within this shrine like a
nightmarish bookstand beckoning to be used.
I have a thing to put it there.
There you go.
Oh, I got it back.
Nice.
This looks really ominous, so...
This looks quite ominous.
This looks quite scary.
Is this like a final boss?
This game is Lovecraft Pokemon.
Oh!
Whoa, what's happening?
Whoa.
It's draining my sanity as we speak.
Finish him!
Oh, there's more coming.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait.
Oh, it's the same room again.
Wait a second.
Ow!
Oh, oh my god!
Oh, the girls are fighting!
Oh.
There we go.
Finish him.
Oh, wrong guy.
It's okay.
Finish him.
Oh, whoa.
My sanity, though.
My sanity.
Oh, yeah.
I like how the music stops.
I'm like, oh, this part's over.
Or...
Nope, not over.
Just, you know...
Just being a little goofy silly.
Finish him.
Oh my gosh.
Run away, run away!
Ah!
Oh no no no no no no!
Oh no no no no!
Oh gosh.
Finish him!
Oh shoot, okay, just kidding.
Are you gonna also explode into a skinwalker?
Oh my gosh, this guy again.
I wish I had health.
Oh gosh, this guy's not dead!
Oh my gosh, I can't.
He took me out!
He took me out so fast!
Yo, what?
Oh my gosh!
He took me out so fast!
out so fast!
If only you had read the game manual before playing, you
would know the strats.
Wait, I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
I saved, uh...
Oh, this one, okay.
Oh.
Yeah, if only you had read the actual game manual, gosh.
Everybody does that nowadays.
I think I hope it's a joke.
Okay, here we go.
I can't tell what this border does.
Oh, wait.
I take out these guys.
What attack?
Finish them.
Eternal dorks.
What is this?
Why is everybody picking on me?
Oh, and
then these guys.
Oh, my bad.
Finish them.
Be fast about it.
Be quick about it.
Finish them.
Going down to the...
Yeah, I'm getting the strategy guide.
Um, if I do this...
You are sad to sell it off.
Don't worry.
They say don't move during those.
I can't tell if it had completed or not.
Finish him!
Oh gosh, why is this...
Why is this camera angle?
Please.
Please, I can't see anything.
Oh.
You'll hear a sparking sound if it didn't work.
Oh, okay.
Bad spot!
This area sucks!
Oh!
Maybe this area isn't so...
Maybe this area is not so bad as I thought.
Just spam it!
Finish him!
Oh no no no no no no no!
We move, move, move, go rip, go rip!
Finish him.
The cheese zone.
Uh-oh.
Oh, here he comes.
Is this the big... Oh, no.
Oh, my God, there's still another guy!
That I have to take out!
Wow, this guy is coming after me!
Oh, ouchy, ouch.
My sanity.
Oh.
Oh, my sanity.
Oh, my gosh.
You are sanity.
Go for the eyes!
Come on, Karim!
Karim!
Karim, I need you to...
I need you to aim, buddy.
I need you to...
Oh gosh, Karim.
Karim, let's go behind him, buddy.
Let's go behind him and, uh, take out an arm or something.
Okay.
Nope.
Oh.
Miss the reach.
Okay, baby.
Ah!
No!
I keep dying to this one, guys!
No, no, no!
Oh, no.
It's so hard to see sometimes the reach, though.
It looks like I'm reaching him, but...
Hmm.
Good for the chakrams?
Okay.
Ah!
It sucks that I have to keep doing the same battle over and
over again, though.
Darkness comes.
Can I aim because he only has eyes for Chandra?
So, yeah, I guess maybe enchanting gear.
Wait, I just realized.
Never mind.
This one makes it sharper, right?
Like, it's supposed to make your weapon sharper?
Is it...
Lu only works against...
Oh, wait, so it actually doesn't even help?
Finish him.
It does help, just not as much.
Bonus damage.
I don't know.
Yeah, because I took out those guys in one hit, which
usually I do not do.
Finish him!
So it is, I think it is technically stronger, maybe a little
bit.
but...
It looks prettier now, it looks like an enchanted Minecraft
weapon.
Just keep spamming, just keep spamming, just keep spamming,
just keep spamming.
Oh, I caught him!
Oh, these guys are getting back up!
Oh, uh...
Oh, it's just you guys, okay.
Finish him, finish him!
Run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, run, run, run, run, run.
Run,
run, run, run.
Finish him, finish him.
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I have screws on my controls!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, there's two of them
though!
Oh!
Wait, hello?
Wait.
What?
What shot him?
Yeah, finish him!
Finish him!
I did it!
Yippee!
Your Honor, she is cracked.
Oh.
Um.
My gaming activates in the weirdest ways.
My health is not so great, but whatever.
Wait, so what is this?
Oh.
Hi, Karim.
Shaped like a deli.
like a dome.
A pale blue statuette floats gracefully above the pedestal.
Should Kareem claim this artifact?
Yeah.
If I find it, it's mine.
Kareem.
Oh.
We will be together forever.
Chandra?
What happened to you?
Things change, my dear Kareem.
But even though my body is ravaged, I await you.
Who did this to you?
You were gone so long.
Wait, how long was I gone for?
I gave myself to a no more dangerous mistress.
Oh!
Shandra!
She hadn't dragged from my bed.
And in cruel revenge, I'm flenched with knives.
Oh my god.
As the last blades were drawn across my body.
And my blood was healed on the floor.
She cursed that I would only be with another in death.
So much for thinking only of me.
Oh, you tell her!
You!
I have seen my folly and have already paid dearly.
You tell her!
I see so much more now than death.
I know the true value of the artifact which I asked you to
find.
She's not even thinking of me still!
And it is none for us to possess.
If we are to be together again, you must make a sacrifice.
She's just like, think it'll only have the artifact.
Sacrifice?
Why should I do anything for you?
Oh my god, he's breaking free of the symbol.
You lied to me.
Betrayed me.
And you really left for five hours.
You must forget the past.
Oh, girl!
Despite who you are now, you will also become something
more.
Just as I have.
But the sacrifice must be made.
We must remain here and guard the artifact.
Dark things will come to claim it.
Imagine something where it goes.
I think she's cuter this way.
The world will fall into eternal darkness.
Eternal darkness!
The things I do for love.
Okay, courage.
The cowardly dog.
That's what would happen if you kissed me too.
I'd put glue in your mouth or something.
I don't know what just happened.
What
the heck is going on?
I'm going to fix my sanity.
Since apparently Alex is not doing so well.
She is a little...
You guys are sick.
Is this the...
some kind of mask oh it's serene i was thinking of the one
from what's it called how the guy was just like it's
contorted it's disturbing it's spinning out blood from its
or it's spinning out something disgusting from its mouth i
thought it was the same thing but no this guy is serene and
like you know he's chilling now we can go wait I'm not sure
if we can open that door.
I don't know if we have the runes.
There's also this room here.
Give it a shot?
Okay.
My sanity is normal though.
Answer the phone.
Remember me, Alex.
What just happened?
My sanity is fine.
okay oh my gosh thank you for all the super chats you got
any artifacts you need us to find no reason kareem's pain at
the end there is basically what we experience every time
mint is late this no it's it's a hundred times worse when
i'm late it's a hundred times worse who was found super chat
if you'd let mint blue in your i hate this
Oh, it is green.
Just kidding.
Uh, okay.
Um.
I'm not gonna quick spell it since...
On you.
Gladius.
After kiss, I have no mouth and I must scream.
Now we can use it.
For some reason, I kept thinking it was purple.
Oh.
What?
It's not even a room!
Dirt.
Among the pantry contents is a spice jar with a scrap of
paper hidden inside.
Spice jar!
She got us blue.
The kitchen is as empty as the library is full.
A reflection of her grandfather's attitude.
Always learning, reading, studying, rather than eating.
Maybe that's why you died, grandpa.
Peepaw.
If you have to rank them so far, where would you put the
stories?
I actually really liked Anthony's so far.
I thought that one was kind of fun.
Let's check our spice jar.
Firmly sealed glass spice jar.
The faint aroma of Arabian spices is tantalizingly emanating
from it.
There's a piece of paper inside it.
Yes, we shall.
Oh, the lurking horror.
Oh boy!
Did you get the red statue?
I did.
Two particles.
Seltar gone.
What's happening?
This looks like the shadow realm we were at.
My liege.
The future is yours.
The light and the age of darkness has been extinguished.
The pillar of flesh has been constructed.
The master of chaos, the keeper of the ancients, is long
dead.
The planets will be in alignment soon.
All is prepared for your arrival.
Oh no.
I will begin the final incantation that will bring you into
our world within days.
Day is a The next millennium will truly usher in a new age.
Your guardians, now prepare that gate oh favorite chapter
favorite character by the way you can examine the weapons
for details uh wait is the spice jar one your favorite is
what you mean roses are red mince kisses are blue like all
these wisps i'm a simp too
okay okay let's let's calm down a little bit let's we're not
we're not oh that's my body oh my gosh I thought there was a
person standing behind me whoo after playing this game back
in the day my friends and I adopted new term for crazy
classmates slightly slanted a flesh pillar we have a oh this
page is whispering to us we still have this dresser key that
I haven't used yet I wonder if I can go find it maybe In one
of these rooms up here.
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
It hissed at me.
The statue isn't moving anymore.
Because I'm not crazy.
The door took that burst and leap burst.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh!
I got more ammunition.
Nice.
I don't know how I found that.
Oh, very cool.
I don't see any...
Or rather...
Oh wait!
Wait!
No, I said it has no keyhole.
Do I enchant the key?
Let me try enchanting the key.
Oh, it can't be enchanted.
Okay, uh...
You need a keyblade.
I don't have those ruins.
Yes, I do.
This one?
I have this one.
Hmm.
What's that baby?
What are those babies doing there?
What is going on in this painting?
Why is the...
Why is the baby flailing?
Woohoo, it's brick brick.
I feel like I could do this.
Alex searches the drawer for some means of unlocking it, but
can find none.
However, the key is definitely a dresser key.
Okay, so maybe we can't do that one yet.
Create a spell.
I wonder if we...
Do we have the rune...
Oh, whoops.
Do we have the runes for it?
Item?
No.
Nope.
Item...
Project?
Oh wait, this is the one we made before, isn't it?
Absorb item?
Oh, no.
Oh!
Wait, what did I just make?
Oh, no, this is the... Okay, just kidding.
This is the one.
Okay, item absorb!
No.
Enchant the key.
It wouldn't let me.
I tried already.
Enchant item, cast Green Yeah, see This item cannot be
enchanted Mysterious, so mysterious Okay, well we know where
it goes to now at least Or maybe I did say it's a dresser
key And that was a dresser And that's the only thing we have
To open Also, I like how it says this room is basically a
museum.
Isn't that a phone right there?
Isn't that a phone, like, right there?
And it's on.
And also, this lamp is on?
Someone's definitely been in here.
I mean...
Cast green spell near the thing?
Okay, let's try it.
What, like, the one to restore my sanity?
time no well
all right let's go read this chapter i suppose yeah i don't
have the right spell that's what i'm figuring hokey dokey
wow it's already been two and a half hours what we've gotten
through two stories i will not argue that i was shocked by
the sudden mention of one of my ancestors
me to my bones where had this ancient book come from how had
my ancestor stumbled upon it I feverishly began to read more
eager to learn his story it seems that Maximilian inherited
his father's mansion just as I had alone since the death of
his wife and since his children had their own adult lives he
explored the see discover his family roots it's the next
chapter what the one with the gun dumb dumb it has been two
weeks since the death of my father and it has finally come
to me to look over the mansion now i am truly alone i'm
forced to start a new life here in rhode island oh no forced
i intend to make the mansion mine and live in it as my
forefathers have Wait!
To continue the family tradition.
Get this guy a chair, please.
Her action has his secrets, I'm sure.
And in my time here, I have to make them mine.
Heroes and Shatter discussing a variety of different topics.
Some are talking about weapons and spells being used.
Others are discussing the streamer's baby in background art.
My baby!
Oh boy!
I got some pistols!
Oh no!
A desk cluttered with notes and rits.
Mostly business to do with the Roy Vist estate.
Is this like the witch?
The witch trials?
Small collection of Maximilian's medical journals.
References and reports.
Can I take that?
The music?
Is that my dad?
That's George Washington.
Mr. Washington.
Washington.
I'm forced to be here on Rhode Island.
I want to be back in Britain.
Oh, it's a different thing.
Witch's Trials were the 1600s.
Oh, dang it, right.
Maybe.
Oh, what's going on in here?
Hello, sir.
Oh, can I pick up?
I found more ammunition.
Um, hello?
Oh, there we go.
The servant is preoccupied with his duties.
Look at the face I'm giving at the camera.
He owns a musket for home defense, as the founding fathers
intended.
Oh!
Can I shoot this guy?
No.
Maximilian's medical journal used to take notes on medical
and pathological analyses.
Okay.
Yes.
Clean my floor.
No, no, no, no, no.
Come here, come here.
Oh.
Clean my floor.
State of the art interior.
Outhouse!
Polished cheek and mahogany finish.
It is truly a sight to behold and experience.
Oh, boy.
I didn't realize this was the bathroom.
The smell.
I'm getting out of here.
We could have just walked in on this guy doing his...
Oh, that's what his duty is.
These are!
Oh my god!
The door to the servant's quarters is securely locked.
Maximilian, however, can't help but feel uneasy.
An ominous presence lurks behind that door, making the hairs
on his neck stand on end.
Oh, they still have...
What is this music?
Do-do.
Do-do-do-do.
Oh yes, the ghost!
A stained glass window, resplendent with bright colors and
exquisite workmanship.
There is something odd about it.
Perhaps the curious detail of its shapes and content.
Or maybe that the sun is like a bloodied eye?
I don't know.
Might be the weird part about it.
It sounds like a bird is singing the song.
A gritty portrait of a man with an overbearing...
continents.
Hardly a reassuring soul.
Maximilian wonders if that trait was prevalent in his
ancestors.
Why can't I look at every painting?
I'm getting a lot of ammunition here.
I'm kind of nervous.
Skellies.
Okay.
Oh.
On the bedside table is an open letter.
I found a letter.
Letter number one.
A letter written with some precision in long hand.
Dear friend, the antiquity of which you ask is indeed the
tome of eternal darkness.
Or a copy of it.
At least, its secrets are still hidden from me.
For I have been unable to read it, as most scholars who have
tried.
It will remain within the sanctity of the mansion for in the
wrong hands it would be a powerful weapon.
Peruse it if you will, but beware its magic.
It is a harsh mistress.
Aaron Royvis.
Where's the book?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
There's a ruin up here.
Stone tablet.
Yeah.
Hope like that.
Thank you.
What are you doing there, guy?
the servant mutters under his breath not realizing that max
is nearby he appears to be distressed at his lot in life
working all the time oh we've had the baby picture for
centuries
state of the art a mirror's grim reflection returns max's
questioning gaze.
His face racked with sleepless nights and a strange gleam in
his eye hint at a growingly odd demeanor.
Oh, ammunition.
There's a lot of ammunition here.
I mean, good.
Goodness.
I just don't understand what are you doing?
Are you cleaning with your hand?
Like, you're just brushing the dirt under the rug?
What is the, what is that?
What are your duties?
What do they entail?
Like what are you actually doing?
I don't understand.
There he goes again.
He's just brushing it under the dresser now.
He lost his context.
A luxurious fire warms the master bedroom.
Its flickering light It gives both a soft aura to the room's
somber decor and an ominous side to the shadows.
What happened to our cool music?
No, where's our cool music?
Someone's walking?
Oh, a maid!
Oh.
What is this?
Oh, I'm getting dizzy.
Why is he frozen over there?
A maid.
Whilst performing her duties, the servant makes idle
chit-chat about the room's temperature.
Pulling from the weather deck.
Turn around, maid.
She's looking around.
She's like, what other wallpaper can I stroke?
Oh, wait.
The maid has trapped...
You guys, the maid has trapped me.
Wait, I actually can't leave.
Wait, you guys, you guys, you guys.
Oh, thank God.
I was getting Capodone by the maid.
That was exciting.
A letter scrawled by a panicked hand with clotted ink.
Dear friend, the house has been forsaken by the ancients.
Oh, I dare not enter it for fear of my mortal soul.
I would suggest that you leave also.
Bring the book.
It is far more potent tool than you have learned.
And may well swing the balance in our favor.
A.
Royvis.
Ooh.
Mate stuck.
Uh-oh.
I think the house is, um, bad?
I think this is the same description that Alex gives it.
I'm confused why I was able to look over the banister like
that.
Examine.
like whoa my god i feel like i'm getting motion sickness
from this i think this house is kind of bad you guys i'm
getting a bit of a feeling at least these guys keep the
lights on oh another rune
i'm getting all these runes but i'm not getting any spook oh
this is that a baseball bat A pump handle is sitting on the
barrel inside the pantry.
I'll take that.
Cozy fireplace is the focal point of the kitchen.
Lending a good deal of warmth to the austere room at the
night.
Oh, hello.
I think I'm a good...
I would be a good goosujin-sama.
With a kind smile, she asks if Maximilian has an appetite.
as she is prepping or preparing a hearty meal for the
evening.
See, she's so kind.
She's so nice.
What about you?
Are you nice to me?
Do you like me?
Whilst going about her duties, the servant casually remarks
about a strange quality hanging in the air.
This odd comment makes Maximilian feel like something is
quite a miss.
Why would she say that?
There was that other guy walking.
Why did the music stop?
Yippee!
We get the good music back!
Oh, this guy right here.
I wanted to...
Everybody's just sweeping with their hands.
I can't afford brooms.
I own this whole mansion and I can't afford a broom!
What is this?
Bidding Maximilian, a courteous good day.
The servant returns to his duties.
Hello, sir?
Good day to you?
Good night to you?
The servant inquires if Maximilian requires anything of
service.
Oh,
yeah, I get it.
There is something written beneath the image.
When darkness spreads its wings before my master...
The anti-cool S.
Backwards cool S.
Zelototh's greatest foe, the path to truth, will be opened.
Bird!
Oh, the true foe?
So it will be this one.
Aha!
Uh-oh.
Oh, enter secret passageway.
Wait, not yet, not yet, not yet.
The uncool is.
The cool Z.
Hold on.
We have a few more over here.
Sorry, I know I'm at...
Oh!
Is anybody gonna...
Wait.
Nobody's gonna comment on the sigil that's just on the wall.
the glowing sigil.
An oil painting of the mansion's foyer hangs on the wall.
Sorry, foyer.
Max wonders why the artist would paint an inaccurate picture
of one end of the room with such detail and clarity that it
approaches realism.
What a strange thing.
Pokemon.
I see no sigil.
Foyette?
No, Foyette.
Foyette!
Foyippee!
The illustration features a collection of strange lion
designs related to each other in a cyclical manner.
There appears to be some significance to it, but it isn't
particularly evident.
The wall is decorated with a color triangular design.
Although Max has seen this...
I think I just understood why the song is called triangular.
Is it because it's about a love triangle?
The first line is like, who are you going to kiss?
Oh my god, it just occurred to me.
It's just all a macross, truly.
You just read it.
It's literally the plot.
I know, I just never thought of it.
I just never thought of it.
The wall is decorated with a color triangular design.
Although Max has seen this particular embellishment time and
time again, its significance elevates him.
They didn't tell this guy anything.
Okay.
Now we may go into our tiny hole.
The love triangle.
So funny.
Here we go!
It's this room.
Cheryl or Ronka?
I think maybe if I were to watch it again, I would pick
Cheryl.
But my heart is still Ronka.
A curled scroll of aged parchment sits atop the stack of
dusty books.
It is covered with strange diagrams in writing.
Reveal invisible!
Woo!
Oh.
A saber!
Saber!
There's the book.
Oh, nothing?
Okay.
What else is in here?
Oh, God!
An aged flintlock pistol rests on a displaced and fixed to
the wall.
Flintlock pistol.
But we've been getting...
Wait, no, we got revolver ammunition before.
Oh, now I can duel them.
I can duel wield!
Okay, let's grab the tome.
The way he's just standing at it.
Lying amidst the papers on the desk.
Oh my god.
Oh, God, I am so sorry.
It's a strange leather-bound book.
Should Max pick up the book?
Dual wielding, baby.
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
As Max lifts the Tome of Eternal Darkness, a letter slips
out from between the pages.
Deftly, Max catches it as it drops toward the floor.
Um.
Wait, but my people are gonna die.
The letters scrawled almost indiscibly by a wavering hand,
dear friend, as I suspected the ruins of Enga?
Tell you, lads, that blasted Necropolis lie deep under the
sight of the mansion.
The accursed servants of Zelotath are so close, I can almost
hear they're chattering.
What?
secret opening in the basement and from there we can gain
access.
I urge you to gather some men and seal it or better still
destroy that damned place.
I have stowed something that you will find useful on the
upper level.
Look to the light and you will find it.
Oh yes, two shots.
This time I got two shots.
I wish that I could be at your side but my ailment worsens
daily and I know that my time is short.
A-R.
I won't forgive you if you let that cute maid make die.
No, no, the other cute maid.
Okay, let's equip our guns.
Oh my god.
He's punching me!
I'm sorry.
This is...
This...
New weapon, everybody.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
New weapon.
Oh my god.
Please, I'm stuck.
Please.
Please stop following me so...
I'm gonna switch to the sword.
Oh,
al-cha-o-cha-o.
Servant!
Why must you...
Oh, my God.
It's this damn thing.
No.
Please.
No, don't open the door.
Attempt autopsy.
I can't believe this.
What am I...
A new entry has been placed in Maximilian's It can be
accessed from the journal section of the tome.
What?
When the autopsy, when an autopsy has been performed, Max
can view the new entry by turning to the journal section of
the tome and selecting autopsy at the bottom of the page.
Select the autopsy to view using up down.
Pressing A will display it.
Whoa!
Would you prefer to do laps around this room or the MGS1
tower?
Um, I think the MGS1 tower.
The creature wears the skin of people to protect itself.
Bone Thief!
Oh.
Yeah, take that.
Bozo.
I am going to save real quick.
Since I forgot to do so before.
I love to reload.
during that battle.
Ow, ow, ow!
And also, reveal invisible.
Torn scroll with magical equations and notes.
So that's the one at the bottom is the one that is inside
the guy that we're gonna have to shoot up maybe.
But this enchantment, the invisible is rendered visible.
Use it wisely for some things are invisible for a reason.
Immortal kind are not meant to see them.
That's exciting.
That's kind of fun.
I can't believe they turned on me, though.
I missed my old weapon.
What?
Why does it say zero?
Am I out of ammo?
Read the autopsies out this chapter?
Voiced?
Wait, what do you mean?
Needs to reload.
Wait, how do I reload it?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, there's only...
Oh my gosh.
Reload!
Reload?
Reload.
Oh, this is so...
This is so...
Reload!
Oh, oh gosh.
It looks like kind of... Oh my gosh.
No!
The maze is attacking me!
okay i'll chill oh gosh oh gosh my controls my controls
please
this guy seems kind of scared i'm not gonna let him die wait
i'm gonna go back in here and i'm actually going to um do
this spell
and we're gonna reload
oh enchant wait i can enchant it
but i should do maybe green maybe green
um spellless or spellless
cast green yeah but we don't have red so this is all i've
got i know i want red but i don't have red so i have to use
what i got oh my god please holy oh my god oh my god i'm in
trouble i'm in trouble i'm in trouble um what is what sir
this is a great star this is such a great star this is just
a wonderful star this is just really great i'm trapped in
here they're all they're camping
i think i have to use my sword i don't know
No, there's no way to loop around.
We're just gonna...
If I die?
I die.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I'm so sorry!
No!
My son!
Oh.
I'm so bowed.
This is so hard.
I'm so bowing.
Can you imagine trying to do this with one life?
Goofy at camera angles.
I know.
That was so bad.
The bone thieves are nasty.
They are.
I hit those guys the most.
I don't like them.
Good thing I saved.
The darkness comes!
One life, one mint was only a dream.
Okay.
All right.
um
okay I don't know which one's better I'm just gonna go with
green enter by
they spam their insanity I know right they spam the insanity
blast and they're so annoying and just ah Ugh!
Icky, icky.
I picked green because it's my favorite.
That's what I did!
Though I probably would always pick green, not gonna lie.
Okay.
If I enchant my sword too.
So just in case I need to take it out.
Buy more.
Sell it out.
It's hard though.
Oh my gosh.
This guy's cowering.
Eeeee!
And the maid?
Oh my god.
Ow!
I only got to reload.
Oh my gosh, please.
Reload.
Maybe I have time now.
Okay.
Nice, you took it out.
I'm posing.
Yubi!
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
I just discovered the invisible spell.
Is the maid...
Is she good?
Is she...
How's...
How are you?
Oh, you're...
Oh, what?
Excuse me.
Excuse me?
You're just...
Eyes wide with fright.
His head twists frantically left and right as if trying to
see some invisible horror stalking him.
Have you no eyes?
Can't you see it?
He cries.
Why are you cleaning the floor then?
Business as usual.
Oh, I can't sit here.
I am going to go back into the room, though.
That we came from and save so that we don't have to do that
all over again.
Since it was pretty clean the way we took care of it.
Oh.
Save, save, save.
Cast the invisible spell?
Yes.
Alright.
Where are you, buddy?
Come here.
I'm gonna save you.
Wait, but it's reveal invisible.
Wait, which one?
Hereupon, Reckoning, Saladon.
Whoa.
Is my mate okay?
I can't tell.
I don't want to go too close to her.
I'm scared.
But I know this door over here.
Oh.
Um, or not?
Are my bullets reloaded?
I can't tell.
I guess so.
cast it in front of the symbol
so green okay i wonder if it's the same as the um i wish i
could see the camera so i wonder if it's the same as the
fireplace Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
No!
No, me!
Oh, shoot.
What?
I thought I- Oh, shoot.
Uh, I only have one bullet at a time.
Hello?
Stop punching me!
Reload!
Oh, shit.
Oh, gosh, I hate- I hate these creatures so much!
Why can't I only do one bullet at a time now?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, don't these guys, um, dodge these things?
Don't they dodge?
Hold on.
I think they...
Equip.
Come
out!
Nice.
Yeah, the bone thieves dodge and stuff.
Okay, well, our maid was so sad.
That was the most sad thing ever.
There we go.
He just kicks him.
What's this guy?
Maximilian...
Maximilian means business, okay?
Enter by Harrow Selaton.
He means business, baby.
Oh, yeah, let's also...
Harrow by Sand and Selaton.
Look at him!
Look at his stance!
Look at him just...
He's like... I mean... Even if I was one of the bone
thieves, I'd be like, I'm not messing with that guy.
He's insane.
He's dual wielding.
Enter by...
Buy and stop by books at yard sales.
Alright, I know probably doing that is whatever.
But I like to just have it.
Okay.
He said something upstairs.
There's probably guys wandering now.
Uh.
Oh.
It was my gun that's making it glow.
I was like, why is it glowing?
That's so mysterious.
Here.
Max spies an envelope that has fallen behind the pedestal.
Fallen perhaps or been hidden there.
Despite his excitement at the...
You guys...
I don't want to tell you what I just read that word as
instead of excitement.
That's... the music is literally me reading it.
Despite his excitement at the discovery, Max senses
something odd about it.
A sense of evil.
But they said...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Finish him.
Dang, this thing takes those out.
Oh no, that's why they replaced the painting, probably.
Or the, the, what's it called?
Not painting.
Stained glass.
That's why it's different.
Hmm, why is it?
I appreciate that this guy's finishing move is essentially
whacking it with his cane.
and kicking them in the ribs.
Classy.
Okay.
Oh, wait, our letter.
A paper envelope sealed with a glob of melted wax.
An odd rune is pressed into the wax.
There appears to be something heavy inside.
Inside the envelope is a letter addressed to one of Max's
father's aides.
And a basement key.
Where's the basement?
where's the basement um the letter written in a scrolling
hand reads dear friend as i expected the beasts are drawing
closer to our discovery they want the book for themselves it
seems and do not want us to have it in our possession i've
taken steps to ensure that our ilk will not touch the key in
this envelope should you fall prey to their claws the
envelope containing the basement key has been sealed with a
corrosive magic if one not aligned to us tries to handle it,
it will be released.
It will be released, inflicting pain, suffering, and a
grievous blow to their sanity.
Should they have any left?
Be swift with your task.
A-R.
Alrighty.
Downstairs?
Oh!
What's happening?
My sanity?
Oh!
Another God, are you kidding me?
Wait, is it still enchanted?
I can't know.
Oh my gosh.
My, yes, they are still enchanted.
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
I'm trying to get his eye.
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
Uh, I can't.
I can only...
Oh my god.
Come on.
Not the best place, maybe.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Ah!
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my God, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go.
Go upstairs maybe?
He's just chasing after me!
Not even a moment's rest!
Okay, this is good, actually.
Here?
Oh!
Oh gosh!
It gets me every time.
Okay, there's like a big...
There we go.
We got a red rune!
Oh, maybe.
Are you okay?
You okay, Maximilius?
Maximilium?
Maximus?
What's his name?
Okay.
I hear someone sweeping.
Okay, I think it's our guy.
Um, I can't...
I don't know why he's still normal.
Whoa!
Wait, will this help?
Absorb?
Self?
Ah!
Recover spell!
We can now heal!
I think.
Uh, recover?
Nope.
Uh, sign.
Red to here.
New autopsy time?
But where?
Oh, wait, actually, what if I do the spell of Reveal
Invisible?
Will we see the guy...
That we just killed?
Will we see him?
Oh, I thought that was it.
No.
Dang.
I tried.
Oh, I...
Spell list, uh, reveal invisible.
Um, no, new spell.
Red.
Uh, area.
Project?
Is that it?
Nezumi!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Spell 9, baby!
why does it feel like an action game all of a sudden oh wait
spell nine okay hold on spell list reveal invisible check it
was uh narukoth and red gormor
narukoth and red gormor narukoth narukoth and
you don't need to redo spells it's automatic what do you
mean read oh wait what do you mean redo yay ghost made may
cry good evening minto how are my feeling i'm all right i'm
a little sleepy actually
recover enchant item um hold on i'm checking everything
though Anterbock and Maggormore.
Anterbark.
And Maggormore.
There.
There we go.
Okay.
Now we can cast our things to be red as well.
Our items.
And we can heal.
We're good.
Door-do-do-do-do.
The color existing spells stay and have all colors as you
unlock them.
Don't need to recreate the same spells each time.
Oh wait, actually?
Oh.
Reveal.
Whoa!
I want to check though.
I say I did the green one earlier because I thought maybe we
could do an odd like because we went to the sepia world I
thought maybe he was invisible and we'd be able to go there.
Oh, it's locked.
Wait, the basement key
Oh god, these camera angles they're
Oh, they're very resident evil and they scare me
I'm going to spell, enchant, cast, sun, spit, saber.
And then I'm going to...
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, oh my god, no, it's this...
No, please.
Oh my god, I can't fight.
I can't fight.
I can't.
There we go.
Finish him!
Yeah, kick him.
Okay.
And...
Yeah, fight him.
Kill him.
Very resonant evil.
Um...
Uh...
My camera angles.
Finish him.
Um...
Yeah, take him out.
Take him out.
Um...
Is this for my sanity?
Miracle sanity.
This one's my sand.
Here we go, we're not slightly tilted anymore.
Okay, we're in the basement.
Ooh, what's that?
Dirty water.
Scroll of paper.
Oh, damage field.
Is that the one I...
cast earlier or did earlier no what is spell nine the
tattered scroll aligned with curious writing and diagrams it
reads this incantation exerts a force of mythic mystical
power within the confines of its runes nothing may enter
till it is dispelled try spell nine
So it's just like a big, whoa.
It's just a big, um, like, spell nine.
N-I-N-E.
Kimmy.
Thanks for two more runs.
Oh, we got more rooms.
I think I'm going to rearrange my quick.
Oh, what did I, what did I think?
Examine what?
Oh, examine what.
Oh, there.
The pump!
We got the pump, though.
Was there anything over here?
Just check in.
All right.
All right, guys.
My pump.
Oh my god.
It's so ghastly.
It's ghostly.
It pumps all by itself.
Come on, tea.
Thanks for the three months.
The pump?
Come on, baby.
I'm ready.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh.
Spell nine.
Oh, oh, no, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I messed up.
I forgot that I need to stay in the circle.
Um, I forgot, I forgot, my bad.
Oh, damage fields, though.
Yay!
What's this guy?
I can't believe this.
Disgusting.
Thank you.
I'm going to check the autopsies right now.
Maximilian's awesome.
He's so strong.
Let's see.
Wait.
No, I want to check it.
Oh, it's in the...
Oh, check.
Oh, here it is.
Autopsy.
Analysis of Mantorok Zombie.
It has no special attributes or weaknesses.
No special attributes.
It's so sad.
Everybody's special.
It is very weak, composed of dried sinew and skin.
Zellototh zombie.
Limbs regrow as phantom entity.
Phantom.
There's no voiceover?
Is there supposed to be?
I remember there was voiceover.
No voiceover in this chapter.
Oh, um, yeah, my bad.
It's after the chapter ends.
Limbs regrow as phantom entities when severed, causing
deep-rooted insanity in the observers.
Oh, that's why they turn green.
Are those boobs?
Does this zombie have boobs?
Wood.
The wrappings of the mummy are hardly combustible and catch
fire.
easily yes yes we knew that sure does it's on boobs I'm
gonna put my hands up they're playing my song the
butterflies fly away nodding my head like yeah moving my
rapping's like yeah put my hands up playing my song I know
I'm gonna be okay yeah yeah yeah it's a part in zealototh's
cave yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a party in zealototh's cave
whoa um why is there why is this in my basement max is
incredulous at the site a desolate ruin of a fantastic city
built into a huge naturally formed cave jutting spires and
looming buildings poke through the fog light ebbs through
the city crackling in the wake of the energy spilling from a
light source held aloft by unseen forces jpeg city i love
the png long
long staircase oh it's really dark down there like an intern
oh maximilian coming in here like i'm about to mess up this
town.
Oh, what is that?
Unfazed.
What if I do one too?
Oh,
no!
Mine didn't reach long enough!
Save?
Oh.
Um...
It did hit.
Oh, it did?
I don't think I can save, though.
It won't let me.
I think we're just gonna have to...
Uh.
Yeah.
A flinch and go...
Okay, so it did glow red.
Okay, um...
Uh, what was I gonna say?
When was the last time I saw it?
I think it was before I went into the basement.
So it wasn't that long ago.
I don't think it'll let me...
Can I...
Can I attack him?
In fact, I'm just gonna enchant my sword.
Every time I have to go into this...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Thank you.
Paragon.
Don't tell if I'm doing anything or not!
Oh.
Entropargon.
Oh?
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
When it's casting, I can't do anything.
Oh.
Maybe I can do something.
What's going on?
Oh, it's summoning.
It's summoning guys.
Oh.
Where are you going?
I killed your guy.
Nice.
I'm speaking Latin.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
It sounded like something from faith.
I didn't need to save you guys.
Park on Cynthia's park.
The accursed beast was dead, but not without its toll on me.
That was but one.
And there was an entire city of them.
Oh, you're right.
I did not hope to fight them all alone.
Oh, no.
I knew I had to get help.
I knew there was a way I just had to find it can I summon my
own demons oh three months later no way
three months later I tried it I tried to tell them but they
won't listen to me damn them damn their eyes the rats
Believe me, strange creatures, the world empowered from
unseen foes.
No, Maximus!
The darkness.
They left me in a room, a room with rats.
Instead they cheered and chewed me into this forsaken place.
A place of empty souls and fevered thoughts, wreaking a
fetter and decay, thinking me mad with delirium.
The fools cast away their hopes of salvation, but locking me
in this stand beside them
may the rats eat your eyes I am now lost to your cause the
darkness comes it will damn us all
may the rats eat your eyes yeah Huey it's literally me that
darkness comes but That was intense.
How do you feel about that, Alex?
That was...
Oh.
To be continued, the battle is won, but the...
The War Against the Darkness Rage is on!
This isn't really happening!
Whoa, whoa, I gotta restore my sanity.
Sand.
check well I thought for real it was actually gonna be like
continuing the next game that was so awesome cool so now we
have the spell to reveal the door and insert disc to
everybody yeah eternal darkness to never happen wasn't it
Wasn't it like there was a spiritual successor And then like
that had to get cancelled or something There's still this
whole room That um Still not sure what to do here So we'll
just ignore it for now Save Thank you
The dresser Yes The dresser Maybe now we can Okay so we have
the door We have the door down here then we have the dresser
all the autopsies there's so much you guys are like don't
forget this don't forget that Minto oh guardians oh
gibbering insanity wrought in flesh as though an artist had
sculpted it created from nothing by their mistress Zelotov a
canvas as grotesque as any their bodies No heads, no organs.
An empty husk devoid of the trappings of nature.
But it walked.
It sang.
It shrieked.
A mockery of reason, both natural and mental.
A blasphemy from beyond the veil.
The veil has opened.
And we should not see beyond.
We weren't meant to, never, ever meant to.
Oh, give us the blessing of ignorance.
The happiness of oblivion.
Innocence can only be tainted.
Never returned.
Oh my god!
I couldn't even say anything through it he just sounded so
awesome 10 out of 10 VA holy gal wait does he do this for
all of them corpses lumbering rotting cadavers what
contrivance could have wrought this this this abomination
disease science blasphemous occult rituals how can something
so so dead yet be so alive and hungry i lust for flesh oh
such a lust for flesh and feast upon all the sweet breads a
man has to offer
wow zombie neither the embalming sav of their wrappings nor
the numbness of death could override the dominating masses
that is Zelotov.
Zelotov.
Controlled.
Proded into an existence by an incessant cacophony of
voices.
Penetrating every level of their psyches, these corpses are
coerced into life.
It's like method acting.
Mowing.
Shrieking.
Wait.
No, wait.
Hold on.
I wanted to read it.
A curious lack of internal organs mean no way of
understanding.
Blurring insanity.
Okay.
Sorry.
I just wanted to read it real quick.
The devils inside the servant's skulls were trying to kill
me.
They plotted behind doors locked and barred and planned the
downfall of the human race.
The worst, the worst, the worst.
I took care of the ones around me and stopped their plans.
There are others.
I'm sure out there manipulating us, secreting madness inside
our very heads while our souls are pushed into the corners
of our skulls, watching as our hands do tasks that we have
no control over.
No.
Horrible.
Horrible things.
We must purge them from our midst, kill them all, cut them,
burn them.
It's the only way.
I know I've done it it works oh my god oh my god yo oh my
holy cow if you don't plan on doing multiple playthroughs
you should look up the other autopsies for the other god
enemy variants oh I haven't decided yet but But thank you, I
will think about that for...
So now we use the red here, right?
Spell list, um...
Maybe reveal invisible, cast the red one.
Maybe?
Aha!
There we go!
And then...
Our dresser key.
Director probably just said, bro, just cook.
I know.
Oh, use the dresser key.
Ask your doctor about Zelotas.
What do we get?
Inside is a chrome finished revolver!
And a tattered page from the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Yes.
We got a revolver!
Oh my gosh, it's the best weapon ever made.
Oh my gosh.
A journey into darkness.
Dear Hargoy, Selhar.
Bargoy, Bargoy.
Your guardians have located the heart of Mantarok.
Yes, located within its grave.
As we suspected.
It shall be retrieved at once.
Be wary.
The power of Mantarok lingers still, corroding the universe
around us.
its tomb it will doubtlessly be guarded after these seven
centuries the beast has not been contained mr beast i can
assure you that my binding of mantarok fueled by your very
own power will be enough it is not your sorcery that we
doubt augustus it's your competence best chapter in the end
of time let me out chance comprehend what that entity
represents or what power it can wield we know not and we
know more than thou your future depends on me majesty
without me to open the gates yes yes be quick left our power
and our faith in you ways to oblivion the voice acting in
this is so good I have seen differently stairs
Gosh, the voice acting in this is crazy.
Alright, then before we...
Um...
Before we continue?
The cutscenes change depending on which god you choose to.
Really?
I like the one we got, though.
She's really cool.
Hmm.
I guess for this part...
We wouldn't really know...
Which...
We wouldn't really know which one would reveal the door, I
think.
Oh, ouch.
My bad.
You are a scientist.
Reveal invisibility?
Yeah, but which one would it be?
We have three of us.
Hmm.
Try them all.
Whoa.
With textures.
But there, I feel like it would show.
I feel like it would show, you know?
I feel like maybe we're not ready for it yet.
Oh?
Oh, just kidding.
Sorry.
the little sigil on the ground there and I thought it was
great.
Spell 9?
Spell 9!
Which flavor?
Does this one take out the...
I'm going to try it again.
Dang, I thought it'd take out the force field.
We have...
damage field.
Enchant item recover.
What damage field work?
Maybe?
Boo.
Okay.
Oh, well.
Well, then.
Very cool.
I'm going to start the next chapter, but I'm not, I'm going
to end it before we like get too far into it um and then how
what chapter is this actually i don't even know chapter of
darkness yeah he's more paragon so true um wait let's see
maybe we can see here oh no cinema cinema
If you like voice acting, that goes hard, try Legacy of
Cancers.
Ooh.
I don't know that one, actually.
The main character for the next chapter is actually voiced
by an actor for Jack Bower.
Oh, that was Neil.
You actually got me, Mr. Yuta.
You actually got me.
Later chapters are going to be fun if you really like this
one.
Oh, yay.
Wait, this one coming up or the one that I just did?
Because I really like the one I just did.
The ancient's influence was incredible.
From all walks of life to all parts of the world, their
tendrils crept and wrought their insidious damage.
Their prisons decayed constantly as their guardians' work
continued.
I discovered mention of a breakthrough in satellite radar
imaging that reveal the presence of a hitherto unknown
temple mound in the Ankatam region of Cambodia.
We are in recent times now.
Dr. Edwin Lindsay took it upon himself to investigate the
area.
We're getting closer and closer to our present time.
Unfortunately, the local government at the time thought
differently, requiring that Lindsay find other means into
the country and to finance the expedition.
Ooh.
He found these in Paul Augustine, a collector of rare items
who professed an interest in the discovery and agreed to
help.
after a dysentery riddle two-week venture Lindsay and
Augustine located the remains of an ancient city temple
dating back to the 12th century 1983 oh my god um hello why
is skull face walking with us yes this is it has to be it's
snake and skull face but here it is satellite data was
correct For years, I have searched for it without success.
Here, all along, clouded from us beneath the great ancients'
insidious magic.
You hear mint died.
What are you talking about?
It's an optional and kind of OP thing you can get in this
chapter.
You might want to consider looking it up.
I will give you an early bonus.
Hey!
Yeah, punch him!
Take his gun before you run away?
What are you doing?
Ooh, nice shot.
My God.
What's wrong with you?
Stormtrooper aim.
You are a scholar, Dr. Lindsay.
Not a warrior.
In that regard, I have several centuries more experience
than you.
Don't be a fool.
Die quietly.
And you will not suffer.
Oh!
You cannot escape me, Lindsay.
This place will be your tomb.
Oh.
Just as it is, Manta Rox.
Hello?
What is, what the hell?
Guardians of Zelotov.
Kill him.
Oh, wait.
Wait a second.
Is this a boss battle right up the front?
No way.
Um.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Um, hello?
I was just gonna start the...
The chapter?
Not...
expecting this?
It's just draining and draining and draining.
I got five bullets left.
Um...
I can't hear you over your sludge.
Oh, his face!
There we go.
Um...
Gotta bait it to open up.
Oh gosh.
Ah!
Can I get more bullets, please?
I don't know if that actually did anything.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're a little late.
Your timing, please.
Uh-oh.
Um.
Oh, I can reload.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
Where is it?
Where'd he go?
Hello?
I don't think that did it.
We got our archaeologist brush, a torch, some ammo.
Oh, oh, a shotgun.
Wait, oh, these are shotgun shells.
I was like, oh, we're fine.
on the shotgun ammo.
We got a key-kitty-key a pistol.
Dang!
Our guy is loaded.
Shotgun kills it in two hits.
That's okay.
I don't need to...
I'm not speedrunning.
It's all good.
I'm getting the hell out of here.
Lindsay has no intention of leaving the temple.
Just kidding.
He is determined to get to the artifact before Augustine
does.
No one crosses Edwin Lindsay!
Kua bar, Kua bar.
I should probably save.
And that was a fun start to the chapter.
Why are they doing him so dirty like that?
Why do they look... Dr. Edwin...
What is this one?
Oh, it's her!
I was... Okay, I was confused.
Kiki Ricky.
he's pogging I don't know about that wait this is actually
Vulgan's voice actor no way oh
I just realized we're here statue of a seated goddess where
her neck and wrists should bear jewelry they're merely worn
grooves and flecks of bronze dust have they been stolen by
grave robbers actually by me I stolen I stole it.
Wow, this is the area where we were that girl.
Wait, well, we have to fight her, I wonder.
Okay, guys.
Uh-oh.
I have stamina now.
Interesting.
Thick layer of dust obscures the tiles on the floor.
Oh,
Bronze bracelet has been discovered under the dust covering
the floor.
Don't look at the camera.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm going to keep playing if I don't stop here.
I will stop here, everybody.
I'm thinking, what, two more streams for the rest of it?
Because we got through three, I think, three yesterday,
three today.
Or so.
Two sounds right.
Oh, yeah, two and a half.
That's true, yeah.
Um.
So...
Uh...
Yeah.
We'll see if I... 2 to 3?
Yeah, maybe if we have to do a third one.
But yeah!
This was so fun.
I'm loving all like the different stuff that we're learning.
Like, now that we got all...
Oh, we don't have the tome yet.
So I was like, Where's my spells?
Once we get... Once we get our...
Corpses.
Oh, why can you hear it?
once we get all this stuff or like we have all our spells
now and we're getting cooler weapons and everything have a
good night man thank you and we're getting through stuff in
the mansion so it's it's getting more exciting and um i have
i'm shocked that whatever is going on is all underneath us
i'm a very like what i'm still confused what's going on but
i feel
little more get it also paragon paragon paragon paragon i
think yeah so i have no idea what's going on but this has
been really fun and great job on getting on a hold of the
game mechanics thank you yeah i've uh i think i've mostly
i'm getting more more used to it so paragon paragon paragon
two thanks to try princess thank you um and the chapters
have been really i think i really like that each chapter
kind of introduces something different and um has been
different different feel like it's it's so crazy this game
is so crazy but i'm really enjoying it i can see why people
really like it but um notice haven't been audible i'll
stream
Oh, I realize that I had it turned off, my bad.
But I can hear them.
Oopsie.
They're only audible on my side.
Sorry.
My bad.
I did it so that I wouldn't be confused about sound.
But it should be okay now.
I mean, now you can hear.
but I'm also ending the stream.
Haven't been called a simp once.
Oh, you're a simp.
thank you.
I, I, thank you.
Thank you.
Um, what's another one?
Oh, do-do-do.
Oh, Ah, I did it.
Oh, I should add.
Wait.
Ah!
Please wrap up.
up shut the hell up shut up Murphy
um you said you would add it like two months ago you're
right I need to add that one um why is the zombie kicked up
damn you're right holy cow I never knew that I needed a half
skelly half human in my life before or in my afterlife toot
toot a roll shut up Oh, shut up.
Toot toot toot.
There you set it.
Oh, I had toot toot.
I'll add it.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Arigato, Arigato,
Thank you guys for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I will see you guys later.
Have a good night.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my God.
Take it out.
Thanks for the five gifted.
I didn't realize you could still hear me either.
Okay, now I turn off my...
Arigato, Arigato, chill.
Thank you.
See you.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye now.
Bye.